what's up Carl hey how's it going all
right well [ __ ] have a seat my friend
I'm Julien Howard a master barber I've
been cutting here for 14 years and today
we're gonna give Carl a Zayn Malik style
haircut are you ready Zayn Malik changed
his haircut pretty often he has a lot of
hair that you can change and do this
myself but today we're gonna do one of
his Styles which I think it's like a
high fade textured course I don't think
so well that's okay because I'm here and
we're gonna make your hair look like it
what we're gonna do is give you a nice
high fade around here there's three
different types of face there's a low
fade starts around just a little bit
above the ear mid fade which usually
starts a little bit on the temple area
and that is a hyphae which is usually
anything above here almost like a
military s and since his head is like
round shaped what we want to do is
compliment that by creating some sort of
square structure above to match his face
everybody has section their hair with
your hair you have that nice texture
that you can do different things with it
if I blow-dry it straight it can go
straight or if I just defuse it and let
the curls rock you can have a little
curly hair and then the styling you're
just gonna really bring out some of the
textures by using some sea salt spray or
might use a little bit of a curl
conditioner just to get a little bit
more of those piscina stew gether and
then we're gonna taper up the sides and
give you like a nice gradual blending
all right let's get started let's put
this cape on you
I'm gonna start with my wall seniors I
love these things because it's powerful
and I can they're Wireless and we're
just gonna start doing this nice skin
fade pretty tight and we're taking into
consideration in his head shape so I'm
not gonna go too high
based on this I start a little bit high
and then a little bit after the ear I
started just arching it down just a
smidge one of the most important things
about hair cuts is symmetry if it's
symmetric that it's gonna be good
now I know this is kind of symmetrical
will fine-tune it a little bit I'm just
gonna clean up the neckline
[Music]
now we're gonna use this little and this
TOI know which is gonna get even closer
you see the teeth a little bit more
dialed in so you're gonna see maybe a
little difference of when I'm taking
some of this hair up you're gonna see
almost look like there's less and less
hair because since his hair is so thick
we can really get that nice gradual Zayn
Malik fade style so you can see his
occipital bone right here it's a little
bit higher up mine if you look at my
head is a little bit lower down so we
just complimented the shape of the high
fade to just gradually touch the top of
that so it almost complements his dome
his head he has a lot of wait wait
there's a word that hairstylist used to
describe the hair and the line of
separation and what I'm gonna do is get
that line and create like a little
buffer and because Zayn and the picture
has a pretty high what I'm doing is
creating that buffer a little bit high
and then we're gonna really texturize it
so I'm just following that same initial
base line that I had so since we made a
little buffer I'm gonna start blending
you see is a line right there
that was my first initial base line with
my machine closed now when I opened it I
made another base line right on top of
it so what we're gonna do is put it
halfway a little bit and try to blend
out that line start getting that line
and just teasing it a little bit when I
get to the line I'm gonna flick it out
of the baby
that nice sounds something therapeutic
what almost like shaving someone and you
say something you hear that
well now let's go to the top this is
when the beam chills come off depending
on your hair type you want to talk to
your barber and find out how much weight
do we have to keep here because
eventually what do you want to have is a
nice balance all the way around so the
hair just literally sits on top your
hair without having it to fall over so
for his hair I think we might have to
cut some just a smidgen and get back
that bounce and that lift again I have
different combs for different things
this is one of my favorite combs is the
widest part 3 3 2 this comb is the
perfect tool because it has the
difference with tension your plenti hair
and styling it you can have a little
more natural with the wider teeth and if
you want something a little finer to
really get that smoothness and tightness
in a little smaller
this one is 6.5 the hh6 it's really big
and it's my workhorse when I'm bringing
up his hair I can see that the shape is
already like this so when there's a
triangle on top there's gonna be less
hair than the side with more the top in
the middle so he's gonna flop over like
that we want to create that nice square
I'm probably gonna take about like half
an inch off his hair
[Music]
for this one since his hair is getting a
little bit dryer I'm gonna switch this
is a kimi 5.0 size doesn't always matter
it's the way he floats in the ocean
right or the movement of the whatever
totally cut that out now I'm just gonna
really start texturizing take a section
of hair and you twist it as your it
gives like a nice layer just really
teasing just run your fingers through
here I want to see what you think you
feel feels kind of light kind of crazy
right doesn't feel as dense so what
we're gonna do is just clean him off
real quick and then we're gonna set them
back just so we can get the face nice
and balanced since he has a little bit
of a scruff we're gonna be using some of
this blind barber Bryce Harper beard
balm it's really good for beers cuz it
has shea butter has argan oil and
avocado which is really good for your
skin and hydrates and make sure that
your skin is nice and fresh and clean
now you're all nice and cooled off and
relaxed we're gonna start styling your
hair we're gonna start by applying a sea
salt spray which one is do is use your
fingers and your hands like a rake and
get that waviness effect so I'm gonna
take my Dyson diffuser what we're gonna
do is we're gonna try to extract some of
these curls and waviness out of it you
can like sort clear like this if you
want
using like fingers like a rake to really
get some of the hair up and as the heat
starts like going on top and he's gonna
start more paint here and there but what
I'm doing see the tips of the hairs
I'm like taking little chunks and
twisting with just a smidge to really
bring out that extra texture in there
and then also what I'm gonna do is use a
little bit of a styling gel this is
already made right x-rays and spray this
stuff smells amazing the nice final
touches that it helps it stay in place
so he put a little bit of pomade with a
little bit of shine and what this is
gonna do is really bring out some of the
glossiness to the hair and then what a
nice finisher you can add a little bit
of a a hairspray a light hairspray and
I'm using this orb a hair spray because
it's very light and it's a fine mist so
it's not like directly putting so much
product in your hair and boom there you
go you ready to see your hair my friends
do it let's show you nice very different
they're different nice and textured
[Music]
so to match a new haircut we got some
Zayn Malik clothes that I think you can
definitely pull off some rock our
lifestyle recently
[Applause]
[Music]